time is running out if you want your
christmas gifts to be delivered on time
fedex ups and the u.s postal service say
tomorrow is the last day to order online
presents for ground shipping to make
sure they arrive before the holiday mega
oliver is at a fedex facility just
outside new york city on how the
shipping companies are dealing with the
rush meg good morning
nate good morning that's right if you're
sending grandma that sweater by ground
make sure it is in the system by
tomorrow the continued supply chain
shortages and popularity of online
shopping are adding to the delivery
chaos fedex expects to ship more than
100 million more packages this holiday
season
[Music]
when did business really start to pick
up oh i i would say at least the week
before thanksgiving and you've been
going non-stop ever since non-stop fedex
courier raymond wenz logs more than 100
miles per day at work on long island new
york i need a signature delivering up to
250 packages six days a week during the
holidays do you feel like you can keep
keep up the space i don't think anybody
can
fedex says they're delivering twice as
many packages this holiday season as
before the pandemic we sort 6000
packages an hour here nanette mal branch
is managing director of tri-state
district fedex express
what's different about this year the
volume is obviously more higher our
residential volume is much higher than
it has been in the past
the company is hoping to hire 90 000
extra employees to get them through the
peak season and fedex isn't the only
delivery service expanding its operation
ups is hiring 100 000 seasonal workers
as they typically do and they're working
faster than last year they can now
process 130 000 additional pieces an
hour the united states postal service is
also growing they say they've hired more
than 185 000 employees since the
beginning of the last fiscal year
though the delivery surge means longer
work days for wends and perhaps santa
too wenz knows his job is particularly
special this time of year it must feel
good when you see people's faces when
you're delivering these packages
everyone that i i train a lot of people
and
everyone i take out they able will ask
me you like your job
i love my job
he loves his job fedex has 84 miles of
conveyor belts in this facility alone to
help sort through packages now if you
miss tomorrow's ground deadline you have
until the 22nd to ship by two days and
the 23rd to ship overnight but it will
cost you but fedex wants you to know
they are closed on christmas day and
gail i don't know if you saw but we
caught a glimpse of santa riding his
bike yeah
yeah i was a little worried about santa
on the bike i went oh oh tom's is hard
for santa but i love that fedex guy that
just said i love my job he said it was
such conviction
you know they are under the gun right
now because everybody's looking for the
fedex person thank you meg thank you
very much